in Deutschland ist längsten Kampf ums
Auto entbrannt so haben wir diese
Sendung ja auch genannt immer weniger
Autos wünscht sich Andreas Knie und das
scheint sich im Moment ganz viele in der
Politik zu wünschen es gibt immer mehr
Schreckensmeldungen deshalb in den
vergangenen Wochen und Monaten aus der
deutschen autowirtschaft
11 mai der Autozulieferer Fino
automotive mit 17 Eberswalde ist
insolvent 25 Juli der Augsburger
Automobilzulieferer Burscheid und wenig
meldet Insolvenz an betroffen sind 300
Angestellte 8 September der
Automobilzulieferer dr Schneider aus
Oberfranken hat einen Insolvenzantrag
gestellt rund 2000 Beschäftigte sind
betroffen 2 Oktober das Hamburger
Unternehmen Ibero hat einen
Insolvenzantrag gestellt die Firma
stellt Sensoren für die Autoindustrie
her 20 Oktober der
nordrhein-westfälische Auto Zulieferer
Burgers hat Insolvenz angemeldet das
Unternehmen stellt Verkleidungen
Dämpfungen und Isolationen her mit mehr
als 6000 Mitarbeitern Achter November
der Auto zu Lieferer Schäffler gibt
bekannt Abbau von 1300 Stellen Grund der
schnellere Wandel hin zur
Elektromobilität 18 November die Firma
biag GmbH in Bruchsal stellt ihre
Produktion ein die Firma mit 154
Angestellten ist Prozent des BMW
Kühlergrills und des mercedes-sterns
der Mercedes-Stern Herr Koch das ist ja
ja sozusagen eins der größten Symbole
überhaupt der deutschen
Automobilindustrie das kleine Werk das
diesen Stern herstellt hat jetzt die
Produktion einstellen müssen fährt hier
gerade was ordentlich gegen die Wand in
der deutschen Autoindustrie ja und das
sind ja erst die Vorboten die wir hier
vernehmen die Firma die ist im
mercedes-benz-stern im Hersteller hat
noch in eine neue galvanisierungsanlage
investiert hier werden insbesondere die
hohen Energiekosten dieser Firma
letztendlich den Chaos machen ich hoffe
dass die Firma überlebt wie viele andere
auch aber es sind wahnsinnig viele
mittelständische Betriebe die momentan
am Existenzminimum an der Grenze
mittlerweile existieren müssen ich mache
mir größtes Sorgen wie diese Firmen
teilweise über den Winter kommen und ich
hoffe sehr dass ich eine Lösung geben
wird dass wir diesen Firmen die
teilweise
Weltmarktführer sind ihren Segmenten die
wirkliche Champions versteckte Champion
sind die Dinge können die anderen noch
nicht können glauben
noch nachkommt was befürchten sie ich
befürchte dass wenn es so weitergeht
dass gerade die Zulieferbetriebe der
zweiten dritten vierten Ordnung also
nicht die ganz großen die leiden auch
die kontinentals die Chef hat sie
genannt wurden aber die dahinter sind
die zuzuliefern die Firmen die kämpfen
100 Jahren jetzt kommen noch die
Energiekosten sind meine Größenordnung
worüber reden wir da wie viele Firmen
wie viel
Arbeitsplätze wie viele Stellen sind
dort in Gefahr ich kann ihn nicht die
genaue Zahl sagen aber die verschiedenen
Aussagen die man hört sind das teilweise
bis zu ähm also hohe fünfstellige
Beträge an Arbeitnehmern gefährdet sind
und das schlimme ist das sind ja hoch
bezahlte
IG Metall Tarifverträge das sind
Menschen die ein hohes Einkommen haben
und es ist nicht nur Leute die für 12 €
im Jahre Arbeitsflächen 13 € sondern
wirklich auch toll verdienen und damit
auch wiederum das Geld weiterleiten und
dann in ihren sozialgemeinschaften auch
wiederum für florierendes Geschäft beim
Blumenhändler etc sorgen und die fallen
weg und das ist dramatisch Leben ist die
Automobilindustrie sie sind
daimler-ingenieur sie haben ganz viele
Patente sind sozusagen autoerfinder in
ihrer Biografie wenn Sie jetzt auf die
Automobilindustrie auf diese aktuelle
Krise schauen wie viel davon ist
hausgemacht also ich würde es gerne
präsentieren dürfen ich war dann 10
Jahre in untertür kam habe dort
nutzfahrzeugmotoren entwickelt in dem
ganz fantastischen Team wir waren bei
jeder Emissionsstufe wirklich
Weltmeister wir haben das ganz ganz toll
gemacht mit der tollen Mannschaften seit
9 Jahren darf ich eben in Karlsruhe
Institut für Technologie das ganze
Themenfeld der Antriebstechnik eben in
Forschung und Lehre vertreten und ähm
wir leiden alle drunter das seit vielen
vielen Jahren dieses Themenfeld
nachhaltige umweltfreundliche
Antriebstechnik mit Verbrennungsmotoren
auch als moderne Hybride das ist keine
Stellenwert hat da gab es natürlich auch
verschiedenen Frau carpek wenn sie das
Hören für das Verbrenner aus ja ganz
wichtiges Ziel jetzt auch der aktuellen
Bundesregierung vor allen Dingen der
Grünen auch auf EU-Ebene das Verbrenner
aus beschlossen jetzt wie viel
Arbeitsplätze nehmen Sie dafür in Kauf
beschlossen wir wollen natürlich
überhaupt nicht das Arbeitsplätze
vernichtet werden sondern im besten Fall
werden diese Arbeitsplätze transformiert
und ich finde das natürlich
ausgesprochen bedauerlich dass jetzt
gerade so viele Firmen Insolvenz
anmelden sie keine Verantwortung das hat
nichts mit ihrer Politik zu tun oder das
ist ja eine Entwicklung die sich in den
letzten produzieren in den letzten zwei
drei Jahren
entwickelt hat bzw ja und strukturelles
Problem hat zum einen haben wir durch
die corona-pandemie erste
Schwierigkeiten gehabt dann hat mir die
Zulieferer Ketten Schwierigkeiten jetzt
haben wir steigende Energiepreise und so
weiter das sind alles Herausforderungen
die bestimmte Unternehmen einfach nicht
mehr packen weshalb ich finde das ist
Verantwortung von Politik ist hier zu
schauen wie man möglichst vielen
Unternehmen auch unter die Arme greifen
kann ich finde das diese aktuelle Krise
die ähm ganz viele Unternehmen unter
immense Herausforderungen stellt darf
man nicht gegen das allgemeine Thema ich
finde das allgemeine Thema ist aber ein
anderes und das haben sie gerade ein
richtigerweise gesagt es gibt in
Deutschland eine zulieferstrategie oder
eine zuliefer-pyramide die natürlichen
ganz sich eigenes Bedürfnis hat so lange
als geht die eigenen Produkte zu
verkaufen wenn jetzt aber China
beschließt dass wir in 2030 sie nur noch
Elektrofahrzeuge abnehmen wenn die
Europäische Union beschließt das ab 2035
ist nur noch Elektrofahrzeuge zugelassen
werden dann
muss dann muss finde ich auch der
deutsche Markt und auch die deutsche
Politik rechtzeitig ein Hinweis geben
dass man sich in diese Richtung
weiterentwickeln aus sie wollten das ich
will politisch natürlich als
grundsätzliches Ziel dass wir auf
nachhaltige
Antriebsformen umsteigen aber ich will
nicht die Insolvenz von Firmen das muss
man mal klar sagen herr Schäffler ist
das naiv dass man sagt einerseits will
man das und auf der anderen Seite für
die Arbeitsplätze wollen wir aber dann
nicht verantwortlich sein sie ja tragen
das ja mit in der aktuellen am naja aber
wir haben als FDP dafür gesorgt dass auf
europäischer Ebene das Verbrenner aus
eben nicht stattfindet sondern das ab
2035 auch synthetische Kraftstoffe
weiter
verbrannt werden dürfen in einem
Verbrennungsmotor das heißt es wird eben
kein Verbrenner ausgeben sondern
das Kernproblem ist dass man alleine auf
Elektromobilität gesetzt hat ja und da
ein industriepolischen Großversuch
gemacht hat
dessen Folgen wir jetzt eben erleben und
die Welt hört ja nicht in Europa auf
Mann wer hat wer hat darauf Regierung
die Grünen ja das ist ja ein Plan
gewesen der schon über viele Jahre jetzt
läuft
umgesetzt wurde und die Industrie also
vW macht nach wie vor Gewinne oder BMW
aber die machen jetzt ihre
Produktionsstätten eben im Ausland und
in Deutschland wird Elektromobilität
vorangebracht aber Werke werden in
Brasilien in Südostasien mal aufgebaut
und der Verbrennermotor wird weiter
existieren und das ist im Kern ein
Riesenproblem für die Schlüsselindustrie
in Deutschland
funktioniert ja gar nicht eh
funktioniert ja nicht richtig weil wenn
man sich das ganze mal anguckt
es ist nicht richtig ausgereift ein
Verbrenner mit den sogenannten e-tuals
also mit synthetischen Kraftstoff das
würde ja funktionieren während E-Autos
die rechnen sich wenn die 200.000 km
gefahren haben solange fährt kein E-Auto
das wissen wir auch wie die Batterien
entstehen wie die entsorgt werden wie
die gelöscht werden das sind alles
riesige Probleme die wir da haben die
wir uns da auch selber schaffen dann
machen wir den eigenen Arbeitsmarkt eine
Kernkompetenz kaputt Deutschland baut
die besten Autos der Welt diese
Industrie die killen wir komplett dann
holen chinesische
wurde ja damals schon von der großen
Koalition beschlossen im Prinzip und
jetzt wird es weitergeführt aber es muss
jetzt mal wirklich die Kirche wieder ins
Dorf bringen das ist ein Projekt was wir
seit 35 Jahren machen wieder ein
Strukturwandel haben wir können es
natürlich so machen wie der
Kohleindustrie wie der Stahlindustrie
wieder Textilindustrie an etwas
festhalten was so nicht mehr gängig ist
wir müssen uns modernisieren und
natürlich wird immer mehr
Produktionskapazität nach China
verlagert werden immer mehr F&E
Geschichten nach China verlagert china
hat aber die die Zeichen der Zeit
erkannt und hat ganz andere
Rahmenbedingungen entwickelt das heißt
wenn wir jetzt nicht anfangen bei uns in
unserem heimatwerken endlich mal auf
etwas anderes umzustellen was sauberer
ist
muss man regenerativ erzeugen wir
schaffen es nicht mehr mit Strom wenn
wir das jetzt endlich mal schaffen
endlich mal der Struktur was heißt IG
metallübung wir machen gerade
Automobilindustrie eine und kaufen
so viel Strom haben wir doch gar nichts
mehr über die Diskussion 1 es ist nicht
so dass die Welt sagte Verbrenner ist
schlecht das ist in Europa sagen china
hat eine ganz klare Strategie China sagt
wir wollen in Zukunft sowohl moderne
Elektrofahrzeuge anbieten da wollen wir
natürlich spitze gehören China sagt aber
auch ganz klar wir wollen
Weltmarktführer werden bei modernen
Hybridantrieben chinesische Firma Chili
kaufen Daimler kaufen Volvo kaufen
Renault Stück für Stück auf und wollen
Weltmarktführer ab es werden rein
Batterie elektrisch
also daimler baut seine Autos noch in
China wir kaufen in Zukunft ansonsten
chinesische Verbrenner oder wie wie
sieht die Zukunft aus China kann doch
kein Vorbild sein China kann doch kein
Vorbild sein wenn man sehen dass das
Land ist das mit am meisten CO2
verbraucht und wir wollen doch gerade so
deshalb wollen
doch alles so wunderbar wenig CO2
verbrauchen auch wenn alle Autos die bis
zum heutigen Tag gebaut worden sind alle
zusammengenommen verbrauchen immer noch
weniger CO2 als damals der eher verläuft
oder so ähnlich dieser unterschiedliche
Vulkan
der damals die Aschewolke
hochgeschleudert hat und da da gab es
auch keine Beschwerden ich sag das nur
mal dass
das Auto der antikresse
verstehen
wir waren bei den Arbeitsplätzen was
passiert mit den Daimler Arbeitsplätzen
die die hier den Verbrenner gebaut haben
künftig wird in China der Daimler
Verbrenner gebaut ja das wird alles
Stück für Stück verlagert werden wir
verlagern unsere Betrieb ist bereits
heute so in diesem komplizierten
Geflecht und nicht nur die endfirma der
VW der Audi der anders ein Motor baut
sondern auch Teile Zulieferern halte
zugeliefert werden müssen ist es heute
schon so dass die Firmen nicht mehr die
deutschen Zulieferer finden ja sagen ich
kann hier nicht mehr noch Geld
investieren dann
in chinesischen die dann
zulieferbauteile in deutschen Motoren
liefern
machen wir hier unsere Arbeitsplätze
dicht und dieselben Autos ankünftig in
Shanghai gebaut man muss jetzt aber auch
mal die Geschichte von der anderen Seite
betrachten 2016 als wir in Berlin in die
Regierung gegangen sind gesagt wir
wollen unsere Busflotte super alte
Diesel Busse umstellen auf Elektrobusse
und dann haben wir einmal gesagt wie
viel brauchen wir wo kriegen wir die her
und die einzigen die in der Lage waren
Elektrobusse zu liefern weil China haben
wie gesagt wollen
die Industrie eingesteckt hat das selber
gebunden
in der Lautstärke wir wollten keine
chinesischen Busse wir haben gesagt wir
wollen über Daimler kaufen weil wir hier
eine Verpflichtung sehen war schwierig
weil Daimler nicht lieferfähig war weil
es an der Stelle einfach entschuldigung
aber diese Entwicklung verpennt wurde
sich Hamburg Berlin Niedersachsen und
Hessen zusammengetan haben und gesagt
haben wir geben Großauftrag auf und wir
halten es ein paar Jahre jetzt mit einer
Brückenlösung von Diesel Bussen noch aus
um Daimler die Chance wir haben also
keine Arbeit
produzieren Frage gibt es doch ja nur
weil sie ein paar ankündigen zu kaufen
produzieren ja nicht morgen
Entschuldigung also ihr Plan ist jetzt
vor kapic sieht zwingen mit dem
Verbrenner aus die Unternehmen dazu dann
eben alternative Anfänger überhaupt gar
niemanden sondern ich habe lange im
Europäischen Parlament gearbeitet da
haben wir schon vor 20 Jahren gesagt
wenn die deutsche Industrie die
Entwicklung
verpennt verschläft nicht mitgeht dann
wird sie irgendwann ein
Wettbewerbsnachteil haben
die Verantwortung dafür geben dass die
Industrie hier nicht entsprechend sind
dann weg darauf können wir uns ja
einigen in der in der Runde das genau
das passieren wird aber sie tragen das
alles mit herr Schäffler das heißt wir
gucken jetzt so wir zeigen noch mit ein
bisschen mit dem Finger auf die
Industrie und sagen ah die haben das
wieder verpennt die letzten 10 20 30
Jahre und so weiter aber die
Arbeitsplätze sind dann in China ja gut
wir 2016 hatten wir
noch doppelt so viel Arbeitsplätze in
Deutschland in der Automobilindustrie
als wir das heute haben und das hat
natürlich seine Ursache und die liegt
natürlich im politischen Entscheidungen
die Vorgängerregierung getroffen haben
wir haben auf als FDP ich habe es schon
mal gesagt dafür gesorgt dass auf
europäischer Ebene der Verbrennungsmotor
ab 2035 nicht aus ist sondern dass er
weiter existieren kann und das finde ich
erstmal ein großer politischer Erfolg
weil diese diese technologieoffenheit
das ist ja eigentlich das fehlende das
Problem was wir aktuell haben alle haben
auf Elektromobilität gesetzt aber es
gibt ja viele es gibt ja viele andere
Antriebstechniken auch noch und warum
nutzen wir die nicht und schauen was
dann am Ende am besten funktioniert und
was Sie am Markt durchsetzt
[Musik]